you ever see uh the rock it's his best
performance and be
cool we played the gay dude the gay
bodyguard
he's so good in that really and vince
vaughn is all ee weezy
ee weezy he's like come on baby i'm
clowning baby
i'm clowning baby you don't know what
i'm talking about
that's his best role there he is he's a
gay bodyguard it's so funny oh i
remember this whoop that trick remember
no that's the trick get them find it
come on man find it yeah
oh hustle and flow yeah yeah that's a
good one
oh play get one
he's all come on find it
they want to emmy for this yeah they did
yeah three six mafia
yeah three six get em
get em get em
this is it boy yeah play this at my
cousin's funeral dude
at my funeral dog you want it yeah and
just start [ __ ]
making it rain with my ashes
oh yeah we'll get that ash gun yeah yeah
ooh just like
like one of those t-shirt guns at the
nuggets game who's ready to be or make
some noise and you'll come out jump into
a couple flips yup
start it off right and then we'll shoot
your ashes into the
crowd and then you play the chicago
bulls uh theme song before jordan came
out on the starting huh
you know what i'm talking about nick
bring that [ __ ] up
forget the name of it this can play at
my funeral though
see everyone's gonna be sitting down and
the light's gonna be off this way
thank you for coming thank you for going
at 6'4 250 pounds
but now but now 2 ounces
but now two ounces it used to be six
four 255 pounds
knocked out johnny curtis knocked out
johnny curtis
he's coming in at one and a half inches
of inches
two ounces
from denver colorado
he's big he's brown he's actually
gray now brendan
shoot the ashes into the crowd shoot a
couple t-shirts out there a couple
t-shirts they need t-shirts
kind of stinging at funerals a couple
meet me at two ounces shirt
[Laughter]
buzz buzz dad dad shirts that'd be sick
wow
dead gang bro the toughest thing i think
about
dying probably is just
think i think are you just worried about
all your stuff you know
i don't think you give a [ __ ] i mean i'd
be worried about my shoe collection but
outside that
take your shoes look what happens to all
your stuff you know and then where are
you going you go on that that
death journey you know no one knows
about it man
i heard your body that's what i don't
know who says this but they say when you
die
your body release like releases all the
dopamine like all sorts of [ __ ] so you
don't feel anything you just go into
like
like you're basically on dmt dang and
you go to where you just
some people go up to the big man some
people go to the bad man
damn and we can guess who's going where
here
yeah this could be hot nick
it's gonna be hot be hot bring your
speedo
[Laughter]
place in all beds imagine we show up in
hell and nick's down there trying to get
a producer job
nick's like talking to satan like look i
think yeah it's
you're doing fine but you could be doing
a
lot
trying to convince the devil to lose his
money on a parlay
yeah if you want odzimir dude that's
fine i just wouldn't take that
i just you know i won't bet the house on
that's all i'm saying in this
[Music]
is